- [Narrator] Country music.
(country music)
And grabbing your partner for a Do-si-do.
You probably have a fuzzy
memory of trying to master
these moves in middle school
gym class, am I right?
So why were we all forced to couple up
and endure this embarrassment?
Well, it's all thanks to Henry Ford.
- [Man] Now grab your
partner and Do-si-do.
- [Narrator] He was the father of the car
and the assembly line.
But here's a little known fact.
Henry Ford loved to dance,
especially with his wife Clara.
Square dancing has deep
roots in American culture
dating back to Colonial Times.
It remained popular
until the waltz and polka
went mainstream in the 19th century.
So in the 1920s, Ford took
it upon himself to revive
the old tradition.
- [Man] Let's do it y'all.
- [Narrator] He opened a
ballroom in his hometown
and encouraged his factory
workers and their families
to take part.
He felt square dancing
helped teach manners,
exercise, values, and grace.
Soon after, he worked to
create a National Square
Dancing Program.
Boards of Education across
the country started endorsing
Ford's mission, and since then,
students have been taught to square dance.
Today, 24, states still
list square dancing
as their official state dance.
So if you feel like reliving
awkward gym class moments
I'm sure you can find
square dancing lessons
somewhere nearby.
- [Man] All jump up and never come down.
Swing your pretty girl ‘round and ‘round.